I'm sure Gary Gilbert enjoy Jordan or oh
it's tame it feels great it's
it's my favorite Ward show this is a
beautiful day on the beach we're back
yard with garden state in 2004 existence
wait seven years seven years done years
and
great going to be back
another
terms it's so hard say yeah the
producers career is very you know it's
about a body of work it's a long sort of
journey and all the films that are sort
of put behind here it's like with actors
with writers directors it's like you can
pop very suddenly you make one film with
flip this over here last card state
right oh seven years ago so there are
seven years old mediocre pillow
two legs have not made
I think it's a Jewish boy that the whole
collaboration yeah I'm really the
filmmaker you never know when you're
shooting a film
we have no idea if it exceeds our
expectations in every way should
everything else you can only sort of
know what you like and make what it like
they're all sources it all starts to the
script and if you love the script love
the stories we love the filmmaker and
one of the cash has the right
ingredients and go for it but even then
sometimes goes work exactly
alright
I really like I just seen him right
there i love the docking free gift shop
I thought that was killer we're just
going I really like did you see winter's
bone yeah great movie yeah Black Swan
feeling really really credibly door
great then
to a white suit
all day thank you so much they take care
thank you